[Musique]
merci Madame
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Alexis Corbière bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ça va vous-même député
la France
insoumise et la Seine-Saint-Denis on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Stéphane
Vernet de Ouest-France bonjour Stéphane
bonjour ravi de vous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle saison également on va
commencer en parlant et un lycée
Corbières de ce qu'a dit Emmanuel Macron
hier en fin d'après-midi Emmanuel Macron
qui a donc pris la parole sur la
question de l'énergie l'appel à la
sobriété les Français être au
rendez-vous de cette sobriété en
réalisant 10% d'économies d'énergie il
demande notamment de ne pas mettre le
chauffage à plus de 19 degrés cet hiver
vous de soutenez dans cet appel
il faut effectivement
ne pas mettre il faut faire des
économies mais comment dirais-je c'est
un peu gag cet aspect c'est à dire que
les Français n'ont pas attendu Emmanuel
Macron ont vu du prix de l'énergie pour
ne pas faire de gaspillage donc c'est un
peu décalé moi je me méfie toujours
quand un président un peu désarmé
renvoie tout à des comportements
individuels faut fermer le robinet quand
on se brosse les dents quand l'énergie
coûte très cher n'ouvrait pas les
fenêtres bah oui mais les Français qui
calcule je veux dire l'ont bien compris
Emmanuel Macron non mais là en
l'occurrence ce qu'il a proposé hier qui
est l'élément de communication n'est pas
quelque chose de significatif il faut
aller vers des alors il l'a dit au cours
de la conférence de presse il y a des
premières mesures qui sont prises mais
c'est plus en termes des fois de
gaspillage significatif qui existe
parfois dans certaines grandes
administrations on peut réfléchir à
comment on n'est pas nécessairement
obligé de laisser allumer des bâtiments
entiers j'ai vu que la discussion est
engagée moi j'étais sensible au fait que
les panneaux publicitaires prendre qui
sont allumés dans toutes nos villes il y
en a notamment je pense à 9000 panneaux
publicitaires qui sont souvent dans les
aéroports c'est la consommation qui sont
allumées toute la journée c'est la
consommation d'une ville de 80000
personnes par exemple il y a des choses
qui sont vraiment pas indispensables au
contraire qui participent pour ce qui
est la publicité là je suis en train de
me décaler mais c'est pas secondaire
parce qu'il faut faire peser le poids de
sobriété sur les entreprises et pas sur
les ménages c'est ça notamment enfin je
veux dire renvoyer aux gens leur dire
que c'est par des comportements
individuels qu'on va faire face aux
problèmes que nous avons me semble
comment dirais-je voilà pas adapté pas
la mesure d'autant que je le répète que
ces comportements individuels évolueront
non pas à l'écoute du président de la
République mais tout simplement au vu de
la facture parce que les Français
comptent et ont bien compris que cet été
fait cet hiver pardon on va faire
attention il le font de manière générale
et en même temps comme dirait Emmanuel
Macron il y a eu déjà l'hiver dernier 12
millions de Français qui ont eu froid
qu'est-ce qu'on fait vis-à-vis d'eux là
j'ai pas entendu de répondre voilà bon
donc la suite on va peut-être en parler
aussi des montres que il y a des choses
qui sont politiquesment encore confuses
sur l'énergie il y a eu d'autres
propositions ou d'autres annonces qui
ont été faites le président de la
République a évoqué la possibilité en
cas de coupure du gaz russe d'échanger
du gaz français avec les Allemands
contre de l'électricité allemande
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire pourquoi
la France a besoin d'électricité la
France a besoin d'apporter l'électricité
de l'Allemagne c'est une bonne question
précisément il faudrait la poser à ceux
qui nous ont dit pendant des années le
nucléaire assuré notre total
indépendance qui avait rien d'autre qui
devait être pensé par le nucléaire que
nous voulions retourner à la bouche etc
on a un problème manifestement
nucléaire notamment dans l'entretien des
centrales il y a 32 réacteurs fermés
aujourd'hui qui nous conduit à devoir
importer l'électricité alors précisément
moi je n'ai jamais exaucé le pouvoir
donc si la question doit être posée de
manque d'anticipation et de prévisions
c'est pas à ceux qui comme moi portent
une autre conception y compris de ce que
doit être notre indépendance énergétique
qui est là aussi on réfléchit sur du
temps long c'est-à-dire que à une époque
en raison notamment l'engagement du
général de Gaulle on a investi dans le
nucléaire à une époque où ça a apporté
ou en fonction sans doute des
développements de la science on pensait
que c'est s'il y a une certaine
efficacité mais nous pensons depuis
maintenant 10 ans qu'il faut
tranquillement engager une bifurcation
pour sortir du tout nucléaire notamment
nous avons pris la France au niveau
européen des engagements d'aller vers
d'autres sources d'énergie renouvelables
nous devrions si nous respectons
seulement nos engagements être à 23%
d'énergie renouvelable dans l'année qu'à
14% là on a pris du retard c'est la
faute notamment d'Emmanuel Macron et
c'est la faute des gouvernements
précédents ce qui se passe en plus c'est
qu'on vieillissant donc qui se retrouve
c'était assez inattendu de la part des
scientifiques face à une corrosion
inattendue du sans doute à ce que ce
parc est vieillissant on a aussi en
raison du réchauffement climatique une
situation on a eu des cours d'eau qui
sont nécessaires refroidissement de
centrale nucléaire qui a amené à des
ralentissements de fonctionnement bref
on a un parc qui est un peu inadapté
avec ce goulot d'étranglement notamment
en raison de la guerre en Ukraine qui
complique un peu les choses parce que
certaines centrales ont besoin
d'utilisation du gaz bref mais tout ça
c'est une absence de prévisions à la
fois qui est une responsabilité
politique si j'irais je pourrais
énormément au commissaire aux plans où
on en est là-dessus donc on se retrouve
face à beaucoup de difficultés
politiques et et je suis un peu pour
répondre à votre question étonner quand
donc on en vient enfin on réalise que
nous avions déjà dit par exemple pour ce
qui est jean-luclenchant par la campagne
présidentielle qu'on va peut-être être
obligé de passer par nos amis allemands
pour faire face à notre consommation
électrique vous parlez de bifurcation
l'objectif c'est de sortir du nucléaire
est-ce que c'est réaliste est-ce que
c'est possible aujourd'hui l'électricité
qui va venir d'Allemagne cet hiver qui
va nous alimenter c'est une électricité
qui sera produite par les centrales à
charbon
tout à fait d'accord on est tout à fait
d'accord c'est pas la bonne alternative
maintenant quand toujours pareil quand
on a une discussion sur des chiots aussi
fondamentaux que l'énergie de grâce
personne n'a jamais dit que si nous
étions élus du jour au lendemain on
allait arriver sur je ne sais trop quel
tableau un peu comme à la maison quand
on fait disjoncter on arrête c'est une
question de temps long qui prend
plusieurs décennies c'est des scénarios
politiques qui nous amènent en 2035 2040
mais précisons qu'on tenait à la tête
d'une grande puissance ou qu'est-ce
qu'on prévoit j'observe que ceux qui
nous faisaient la leçon n'ont pas prévu
grand-chose voire même c'est piquants se
sont mis parfois dans la main de la
Russie concernant le gaz il y avait pas
trop de scénario alternatifs je fais une
parenthèse sur la question du fait que
nous puissions avoir un partenaire avec
l'Algérie qui a du gaz ça fait
maintenant 10 ans que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
il a encore répété à l'occasion
français a dit nous avons avec l'Algérie
la possibilité de leur vendre du blé à
des prix non spéculatifs d'avoir un
échange de gaz pour essayer d'avoir une
diversification du point de vue de nos
de ceux qui nous fournissent du gaz même
si on le sait nous achetons surtout du
gaz à la Norvège et moins à la Russie
que ce que parfois certains peuvent le
prétendre nos difficultés ne sont pas
seulement dues à ce qui se passe à
l'Ukraine mais bref il y a une absence
de prévision qui nous amène effectuant
ce paradoxe aujourd'hui est-ce que nous
allons acheter de l'électricité à des
centrales à charbon ce qui n'est pas bon
mais on peut quand même avoir une
réflexion sur le fait que le tout
nucléaire par rapport aux difficultés
malgré tout que que cela pose en matière
d'entretien en matière d'investissement
indispensable colossaux si nous voulions
reconduire notre part nucléaire nous
pouvons aussi imaginer d'aller vers de
nouvelles sources d'énergie énergie
marémotrice énergie solaire Jean-Luc
Mélenchon de la cessé de parler de ça
pendant la présidentielle on y est
maintenant sur cette question de
l'énergie de l'écologie et du sport
puisque dimanche et du sport oui vous
avez appelé vous êtes plutôt sceptique
pour le dire le déplacement de l'équipe
de France à la Coupe du monde avec vous
moi je serais même favorable à un
boycott maintenant j'ai bien compris que
quand je ne suis qu'aux député ça n'a
pas de sens je suis extrêmement choqué
par cette coupe du monde qui va s'ouvrir
au Qatar je mets de côté la passion
qu'on a tous pour le foot c'est pas ça
le sujet c'est précisément en plus un
sport magnifique mais nous allons faire
une coupe du monde dans un pays qui va
accélérer la catastrophe écologique 64
matchs dans une des régions les plus
chaudes du monde dans des stades
climatisés à ciel ouvert c'est une folie
sur le plan sociale 6500 ouvriers selon
The Sun le journal anglais aurait perdu
la vie au cours des des chantiers il y a
plusieurs centaines d'ouvriers qui ne
sont pas payés encore qui ont fait qui
ont manifesté dernièrement qui ont été
expulsé du pays enfin le Qatar et du
point de vue des droits fondamentaux bon
bref
des autorités je suis pour qu'à ce stade
parce que je suis pas naïf au moins que
des voix s'élèvent comme conditionne
notre venue au moins que les ouvriers
soient payés au moins que justement
l'une des voix phares de l'équipe de
France c'est Killian Mbappe je vous
faire réagir puisque hier il y a eu une
dynamique avec Kylian Mbappe et
l'entraîneur du PSG Christophe Galtier
puisque elle aurait été posée la
question de leur déplacement à Nantes
c'était dimanche pour jouer un match de
Ligue 1 ils ont pris un jet privé au
lieu de prendre le train donc on leur a
été posé la question Kilian Mbappe a
éclaté de rire et Christophe Galtier a
dit on réfléchit à se déplacer en char à
voile qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé de
cette réaction je suis attristé alors
que les choses soient claires bon
Killian Mbappé est un jour magnifique en
même temps c'est un homme jeune et je
veux pas lui faire porter sur les
épaules ou est-ce que je veux dire
demander parfois à nos joueurs de foot
d'être exemplaires mais la réaction est
affligeante surtout de la part de
l'entraîneur ils peuvent répondre c'est
à demander au staff à la direction du
club c'est pas notre sujet on est venu
pour faire une conférence de presse
sportive ça je l'aurais compris mais
éclater de rien et après comme le fait
monsieur Galtier qui est un homme plus
d'âge mûr du genre on y réfléchit on va
y aller en char à voile c'est affligeant
et c'est grave parce que là encore je
veux pas faire supporter plus au sport
que que ce qu'il est mais tel que je
l'ai dit à propos de la Coupe du Monde
au bout d'un moment il y a des choses
que vous le vouliez ou non en raison de
la passion que vous suicidez en raison
de l'argent que cela représente en
raison de l'enjeu de société il y a
quand même des choses sur lesquelles on
ne peut pas être indifférent on ne peut
pas être indifférent ce qui se passe au
Qatar et les conditions de cette Coupe
du Monde on ne peut pas être indifférent
réchauffement climatique et la manière
dont un grand club se déplace et si
comment dirais-je la question il n'est
pas affûté pour répondre et l'humour
qu'il fait montre que franchement ces
gens sont extrêmement dézoins l'image
que ça donne de la part surtout de
l'entraîneur que je veux accablé un
homme
français et comme la manière dont
franchement en on peut rien afficher
hormis leur monde de sportif bon moi je
peux avoir la passion du sport sans être
un bout un qui n'a rien à fiche de ce
qui se passe quoi parce que le jour où
vraiment on sera en difficulté enfin je
veux dire même sur même s'ils mettons du
pognon on arrivera plus à jouer quoi
s'il fait trop chaud enfin je crois que
tout le monde le comprend bon sang non
c'est décevant donc merci d'avoir aussi
engagé la discussion sur la Coupe du
Monde au bout d'un moment c'est pas que
du sport c'est aussi de la politique
c'est des comportements et vous l'avez
pointé dans votre question c'est à dire
que quand le président de la République
dit faut qu'on ait des comportements à
la maison et je pense qu'on a pas
attendu mais que les principaux clubs ne
réfléchissent pas comment on peut avoir
une sobriété énergétique ça montre que
ça va être difficile de faire avancer
les choses évidemment juste peut-être
une dernière question sur
l'annonce du président de la République
hier la façon de faire en fait qui le
président de la République dit nous
sommes en guerre énergétique il annonce
qu'il va y avoir des points réguliers
pour informer les Français sur ce qui se
passe sur le front de
l'approvisionnement en énergie eu un
conseil de défense consacré aux
questions énergétiques la semaine
dernière on a l'impression que c'est le
retour de la méthode covid appliquée à
la crise énergétique est-ce que c'est la
bonne méthode qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire ça nous sommes très critiques
par rapport à ça moi je n'apprécie pas
parce que je suis républicain à cette
forme de bonapartisme permanente dans
une institution il y a le grand homme le
chef le chef de gare quand c'est la
guerre il y a le général en chef c'est
le président de la République qui réunit
non pas un conseil des ministres qui
crée de la délibération dans lequel il y
a un peu de publicité qui ne s'appuie
pas sur notamment le Sénat l'Assemblée
nationale pour partager des diagnostics
et amener si on doit notamment passer
par des comportements collectifs et
aussi individuels c'est au contraire
l'idée qu'il y a un stratège qui à un
moment donné réuni qui ne sait pas tout
mais qui concentre tous les grands
problématiques un moment donné il va
nous faire
de la communication mais qui crée aussi
une ambiance politique
une angoisse et une ambiance politique
celle du Sauveur je n'aime pas ces
institutions de la 5ème république parce
que je pense que dans ces moments de
difficultés nous traversons des moments
de difficultés c'est d'idées que un
personnage central lui concentrant là
aussi les grands problèmes du monde et
apportant les réponses va résoudre le
problème ça n'est pas ainsi et ça
fabrique je l'ai dit sur d'autres
antennes une espèce de d'ambiance de
solution de plus en plus autoritaire on
pourrait prendre au problème c'est à
dire que les libertés publiques nous
font perdre du temps l'Assemblée
nationale est une bande de bavard
inutile qui nous fait perdre du temps
etc etc je n'aime pas cette ambiance où
nous l'opposition on est montré comme je
l'ai vu madame la première Nice disant à
limite de l'arc republicain parce que
nous ne sommes plus dans la
co-construction avec bref on a
l'impression que il n'a que eux et en
particulier un chef de l'État qui
concentre le pouvoir c'est d'ailleurs
pas toujours très respectueux pour la
première ministre elle-même parce qu'on
se demande à quoi elle sert à quoi sert
même le gouvernement s'il faut sur des
sujets aussi importants comment dommage
que ça passe par un conseil de défense
moi je suis pour la publicité des débats
des libérations collectives les
problématiques on doit les partager et
après les solutions elles sont discutées
et elles sont d'autant mieux comprises
par les Français il a réagi sur un sujet
que vous portez c'est la taxation des
super profits il a dit qu'il cherchait
un consensus au niveau européen avec le
cas échéant il réfléchirait au niveau
français Vous saluez cette prise de
position alors deux attitudes de ma part
premièrement moi j'ai envie de dire il
nous donne le point c'est à dire qu'il y
a eu un petit débat qui était engagé il
y a quelques temps faut-il taxer les
super profits on a vu un petit jeu
Monsieur le Maire madame borne qui était
pas exactement pareil Monsieur le Maire
disant même moi je sais pas ce que c'est
des super profits bon on observe que
déjà nous on veut engager là-dessus
d'ailleurs on fait même une pétition
taxer super
profit.com.fr qu'on peut signer on est
déjà presque à 100000 personnes qui
signent parce que nous voulons taxer les
super profits Monsieur Olivier fort a
lancé l'idée dans la faire un homme
initiative partagée on va voir si cette
techniquement possible pour avancer
cette discussion ce que nous disons
c'est qu'il y a nombre d'entreprises qui
ont fait des des profits significatifs
inattendus inhabituel et c'est le moment
qui participe davantage à l'effort
national pour que nous puissions tous
avancer collectivement bon donc quelque
part face à cette pression dans la
société qui existe Emmanuel Macron dit
oui effectivement il y a des groupes qui
font des profits et il faut qu'ils
soient sollicités alors après donc
idéologiquement il nous donne le point
maintenant de la même façon que en fait
il crée une astuce on sait plus très
bien ce qu'il dit en fait c'est assez
c'est une esquive pourquoi je dis ça
parce que premièrement ce qui dit est
assez confus il va falloir voir au
niveau européen ce que ça met en place
une contribution c'est pas très bien
c'est ça veut dire si c'est une
sollicitation en présence ou si ça va
être une obligation d'ailleurs il dit
que ça marche pas pour avoir sur le plan
national il faudra trouver un point de
consensus européen tout ça en est
énormément de temps ce qui m'inquiète
d'autant plus c'est surtout quand il dit
Alexandre de ce qu'on a fait avec Total
alors là total qui c'est 15 milliards
dans le premier semestre de de de
bénéfices records qui font et la
ristourne qu'ils ont fait c'est à peu
près 0,3
sur ces profits inattendus si c'est ça
l'ambition du président de la République
de solliciter pour le portefeuille je
répète si l'ambition c'est de solliciter
0,3 0,5 % des surprofises sur les
entreprises qui font ces bénéfices
records ça va pas très loin d'accord ça
ne va pas très loin donc ça manque
singulièrement d'ambition nous nous
pensons ça va être pourquoi pas j'ai vu
qu'Eric Coquerel mais on a eu la
condition des Finances avait notamment
proposé un moment à hauteur de 15%
certains même disent 25 % parieurs
est-ce que ça pourquoi ce serait limité
aux entreprises sur le terrain de
l'énergie telle que la ville président
de la République je pense notamment une
entreprise qui fait du bon boulot mais
le CMA GMC je crois qu'il y a à
Marseille qui fait du transport
notamment ferroviaire qui ont vu le des
profits explosés et qui en plus ont
soumis à la fiscalité des armateurs
grecs notamment et qui n'ont pas eu
quasiment pas d'impôts là aussi eux on
pourrait davantage comment dirais-je les
taxés pas pour leur faire mal des fois
j'entends des simplifications parce
qu'on a besoin de l'argent public pour
aller vers des investissements qui nous
permettent d'aller vers ces bifurcations
écologiques et qui permettent aussi de
répondre à beaucoup de préoccupations
dont on va peut-être parler je pense à
l'école je pense à l'hôpital etc on va
parler de l'école mais juste un mot sur
Éric au calme puisqu'il préside la
commission des finances et Gabriel Attal
appelle à une nouvelle méthode pour
examiner le budget il appelle notamment
les membres de la commission des
finances de tout groupe à discuter avec
lui avant vous irez
juste un truc pardon c'est que autant il
y a des bazars qui sont mis en place je
pense au CNR c'est des astuces pour
esquiver le Parlement autant le fait que
le ministre du Budget discutons avec les
groupes de l'Assemblée nationale pour
présenter mon prochain budget c'est
quelque part finalement un peu oui c'est
dans les clous c'est à dire que comme
l'a dit Eric Coquerel il est présent en
commission des finances je ne suis pas
choqué qui est un dialogue qui soit
engagé qui est un premier dialogue au
niveau de Bercy puis qu'après viens au
niveau des commissions parlementaires
alors voilà vous avez tout dit c'est à
dire que comme la pointée mon ami
Coquerel c'est qu'une fois que il y a
cette opération de communication les
donc le fixe monsieur le ministre Attal
montre qu'en vérité ils ont pas envie de
discuter grand chose ils veulent pas
toucher à la fiscalité de toute manière
ils veulent avancer oui mais bon voilà
donc ils veulent pas toucher à la
fiscalité alors que je pense qu'il faut
réfléchir à un moment c'est toujours
pareil c'est des phrases quand on dit
les Français je vais pas augmenter vos
impôts alors les braves gens se disent
je paye déjà beaucoup d'impôts merci
mais on parle pas d'eux on parle pas des
classes moyennes des classes populaires
mais il y a quand même des gens
aujourd'hui qui font des des qui
accumulent des richesses comme on l'a
jamais vu fait vous avez vu ces chiffres
que même challenge le journal à tester
cinq personnes qui possèdent autant
aujourd'hui que 27 millions de Français
on n'a jamais vu ça on peut quand même
aller sans être spoliateur ni faire
basculer la France dans le modèle de la
Corée du Nord vers une fiscalité un
petit peu plus redistributive justement
vous voterez compte ce but du point de
vue des éléments qu'a donné moi je
répète ce que me dit mon ami concrète
qui a plus travaillé le budget que moi
au vu des banques qui sont données ça ne
va pas dans la bonne direction ça
continue à être un budget qui veut
baisser l'assurance chômage un budget
qui se situe sur le plan de du gel des
salaires mais alors vous m'arrêtez si je
me trompe et le dialogue avec Bercy qui
est proposé ça peut pas être le lieu de
pour discuter justement de la taxation
des super profits il y a le gouvernement
annonce que le bouclier énergétique est
prolongé en 2023 c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle il va falloir financer est-ce
que la taxation des super profit c'est
pas un moyen de ça ça pourrait pas être
un moyen de financer
ce type de dispositif et ce lieu pour en
parler c'est pas ces dialogues là il me
semble que quand nous avons dit banco de
la par la bouche de mon ami et Coquerel
ça va dans le sens de ce que vous dites
c'est à dire que le fait qu'au ministre
du Budget veulent discuter avec les
différents groupes parlementaires et
avec nous en particulier et en
particulier comme nous avons la
présidence de la commission des finances
par intermédiaire de Monsieur Coquerel
avoir une discussion sur lequel
j'imagine que Eric ira avec l'idée qu'il
faut taxer pour fils c'est un une belle
discussion sceptique quant à l'issue
c'est que j'ai lu dans le Figaro comme
Monsieur Attal disait non bon mais on va
le faire mais là pour le coup voilà
c'est le dialogue aura lieu et il faut
qu'il y ait une publicité du dialogue
d'ailleurs que on dira ce que nous
sommes allés dire ce que le ministre va
y répondre maintenant là où on est un
peu et chaude c'est qu'on a déjà
participé par le passé à des réunions
qui avaient lieu notamment à Matignon à
l'époque du covid où on arrivait point
d'information du ministre toutes les
forces poétiques sont là petit tour de
table dans lequel des gens expriment des
accords parfois la communication c'était
j'ai réuni toutes les forces politiques
il y a un consensus et après tu te
retrouves embarquée dans une espèce de
temps jusqu'à ici un mot sur l'école
c'est un sujet évidemment important que
vous connaissez bien il y a une pénurie
de prof en cette rentrée des contrat
actuelle peut former qui se retrouvent
devant les élèves est-ce que vous allez
prendre une initiative à l'Assemblée
nationale sur ce sujet oui nous
présentons là aussi des PPL sur ce sujet
là nous voulons des créations de poste
nous l'avons nous avons beaucoup parlé
avec avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale quand nous l'avons rencontré
notamment les élus de Seine-Saint-Denis
nous étions pour ouvrir en concours
exceptionnel il nous a dit non j'observe
que face à la situation difficile
maintenant le ministre est en train de
dire qu'il ne ferme plus la porte à ça
moi je n'oublie pas aussi tous les
personnels
certains disent parfois les petits
personnels mais si indispensable ATSEM
aesh mal payés précarisés qui doivent
être payés comme il se doit c'est
souvent des métiers féminins 600 euros
par mois pour un travail indispensable
qui doit être titularisé revalorisé tout
ça on va le porter sans doute que à
l'occasion de notre niche aussi on est
en train d'en parler qui aura lieu au
moindre novembre nous allons proposer ça
et on aimerait aucune proposition de loi
oui pour dire quoi j'ai envie pour dire
notamment des titularisations des
embauches aller vers 19 élèves par
classe etc etc aller vers la gratuité
notamment du matériel scolaire là aussi
pour aider mais globalement je termine
parce que je suis quand même élu de
Seine-Saint-Denis non seulement il y a
des contractuels mais il y en a plus
dans nos départements et moi je trouve
que cette j'ai dit c'était pas une
rentrée c'était une sortie c'est une
sortie de l'égalité républicaine selon
les départements où vous habitez vous
avez des fois c'est le cas nous dans le
secondaire 16 à 18% des personnels qui
sont contractuels alors qu'évidemment
dans d'autres à Paris c'est pas le cas
et moi ça me choque une dernière
question rapidement sur la France sur la
France insoumise le le le mouvement va
t-il évoluer comment va-t-il s'organiser
et comment est-ce que vous voyez les
choses
évoluer évidemment
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a exprimé par une
phrase que vous aviez notée il l'avait
dit au soir du premier tour faites mieux
il faut faire mieux faire mieux ça veut
dire pas faire pareil donc il va falloir
s'organiser déjà avoir une réflexion
permettait déjà qu'on est un peu soufflé
on est passé 17 à 75 députés c'est pas
rien un groupe humain qui se met en
place on a nos journées parlementaires
qui ont lieu les 22 et 23 septembre
c'est là que le débat commence comment
on s'organise sur la succession qui se
pose on en est loin de ça mais il faudra
nécessairement se poser la question de
qui est notre candidat en 2027 il y a la
nuque qui existe d'ailleurs quel est le
candidat qui peut-être être un candidat
partagé et au-delà de la personne ça
vient je conteste pas que c'est
important c'est
quelle est la ligne politique et le
discours politique que nous avons pour à
la fois garder ce que nous avons
accumulé c'est 7 millions de voix mais
aller plus loin moi c'est d'abord ça je
veux seulement qu'il y ait pas une
discussion sur à vous garder Mélenchon
est-ce que c'est un nouveau qui sait
mais d'abord qu'on ait une discussion
politique sur quels sont nos le nombre
de faiblesse et à partira ça s'incarnera
peut-être du moins je te souhaite
évidemment et vous viendrez nous en
parler merci à tous d'avoir été notre
invité la une
[Musique]